moi je trouve que cette déstabilisation
d'exécutif venue de l'exécutif lui-même
pose problème c'est premier ministre qui
a dit que nous étions en guerre c'est
premier ministre qui a réclamé de
l'unité l'homogénéité dans une situation
où les français avaient besoin d'être
protégés pas simplement du risque
terroriste mais des difficultés qui sont
les leurs donc je trouve cette séquence
du point de vue des deux têtes de
l'exécutif pas bonne et je le dis parce
que moi j'ai pris mes responsabilités je
ne suis plus au gouvernement j'ai décidé
de faire porter ma parole dehors comme
d'autres mais là nous sommes devant ce
qui relève d'une compétition entre les
deux têtes de l'exécutif
je ne la trouve pas saine voilà f qu'il
fragilise françois hollande tout cas
indiscutablement cette séquence et ne
montre pas un exécutif d'abord concentré
sur sa tâche est en capacité de 2,2
voilà de nous dire comment on fait face
aux différents rendez-vous qui viennent
donc je veux simplement dire c'est que
nous ils entendent que le premier
ministre voudra bien y aller soit
on a bien compris on maintenant que
rapidement les choses se décantent moi
je peux importe qui sera choisi parmi
eux mais que ça ira l'élu oui mais je
trouve c'est surtout l'un des premiers
ministres le chef de l'état donc quand
on entend de la part du premier ministre
des appels à la responsabilité en
permanence et qu'on voit donc série
d'interviews d une envie de coude le
président non ça n'est pas sérieux
jamais